warning this video contains code geass
spoilers all the spoilers all of them
what is up everybody its Anna Mac here
for anime uproar and recently in the
comments to our Code Geass videos we'll
be getting a whole lot of questions
about news for the sequel questions like
when is the sequel going to be released
when do the events of the sequel take
place chronologically who will be the
main characters and all that kind of
stuff so in this video we will share
everything that we know so far about the
Code Geass sequel and about the three
recap films here on this channel we want
to be your go-to place for all the
latest news for Code Geass season 3 but
also attack on Titan season 2 seven
deadly sins season two one punch man
season two and so on so if you want to
stay up-to-date on all these huge
releases in 2017 be sure to subscribe we
will have new update videos coming out
as soon as we hear some news so stay
tuned now I did a lot of my own research
for this video but we also got a lot of
help from our subscribers in both our
live streams that we host on this
channel and in our discord server if you
want to be a part of these discussions
you can check out the link to our
discord server right there in the
description so here's what we know so
far back on November 27th there was a
special code geass 10 year anniversary
event and only a select few fans were
invited and here we learned the big news
that there's going to be a new Cody ass
anime coming out along with three films
that are going to be coming out in 2017
and they're going to be recapping the
events of season one and season two of
cordials
the new anime will have the title called
odious fukatsu no Lucia or Code Geass
Lelouch of the Resurrection sometimes
translated as Lelouch of the revival or
even Lelouch of the rebellion the
director Goro Taniguchi commented that
the upcoming project would star an ally
volusia and not an alternate setting
Lelouch so we know that the original
Lelouch will come back in this anime it
will not be a clone it will not be an
alternate universe the real illusion
back within the same universe of Code
Geass season 1 and season 2 so
the sequel has been described as the
next project so we don't know for sure
if it's going to be a full third season
if it's going to be an OVA like our key
to the exiled or if it's going to be
just a film however obviously we are all
hoping for a full third season and
personally I definitely think that Code
Geass has a huge international fan base
so financially they can definitely
afford to create a full season but we'll
have to see we'll have to wait and find
out the PV or teaser trailer for the
sequel that was shown at the University
of vent was actually leaked last month
and in the PV we got to see a damaged
mask of zero being washed up on shore we
got to see Suzaku and orange being
attacked by someone we got to see a lot
of explosions and we also got to see
Colin Tamaki Oggy lady Kaguya and
Cornelia along with what appears to be
Lelouch acai with Geass inside the pv
didn't really give us that many answers
but it did give us some clues and if you
want to see my detailed analysis of the
pv the link is in the description the
three-part film series that was also
announced will be airing before the
sequel comes out and we know that these
three films are going to be recapping
the events of kochiya season 1 and
season 2 we also know that the original
voice cast will be returning for the
films and they're going to be actually
re-recording their lines and shooting
some extra scenes that we did not see in
the original series which leads us to
speculate about perhaps we're going to
get some clues in the films themselves
about what's going to happen in the
sequel so I'm really looking forward to
these films coming out the film's are
supposed to be coming out in the first
half of 2017 and according to some
sources the first film could be out as
early as January of 2017 which is this
month however we haven't been able to
confirm any of this we don't know
exactly when the films will be coming
out but we are checking daily we're
trying to find the latest news and if
you want to help us out with that if you
want to be a part of it definitely reach
out to us join the discord server we'd
love to chat with you so as far as the
release date goes so far we only know
very general information and that is
that the three recap films are supposed
to be coming out in the first half of
2017 and the actual sequel should be
coming towards that
and of 2017 it is also worth noting that
fans who got to attend the anniversary
event received a secret code and when
this code was solved what appeared were
the words rebirth of the demon now
what's really interesting about that is
that the very first episode of Code
Geass the first episode of the first
season in which Lelouch first makes his
contract with c2 is called the day a new
demon was born and the first episode of
r2 in which Lelouch regains his memories
with the help of c2 is called the day a
demon awakens I think it's pretty clear
that the demon here refers to Lelouch
and actually rebirth of the demon might
be the title of the first episode of the
third season of code geass and that
would be very interesting and this
actually lends credence to my theory
that I first spelled out in the top
three reasons Lelouch was still alive
video link in the description in which I
said that a being with code first has to
die for their code to be activated
so therefore if Lelouch first had to die
if he had to be killed by Suzaku to
become immortal and to for his code to
activate then the word rebirth of the
demon makes a lot of sense another piece
of news that we know so far is that a
special anniversary package DVD and
blu-ray discs will be released on April
21st 2017 the home video release will
include a video of the live action stage
performance that took place at the event
a picture drama that the beauty at the
event a new fukatsu kiss a keno babo
gachi jo short and the promotional video
that announced the new project and of
course a lot of people can't wait for
the special anniversary package to be
released on April 21st and many are
speculating that within this package we
might get more tips and clues about the
sequel as always here on this channel we
will stay on top of it and we'll bring
you all the news first and the last
piece of news that we have right now is
that a new promotional image a new
promotional poster recently appeared on
the Japanese website for Code Geass
which featured a bunch of characters
from the original series from Akito the
exiled the OVA and from the various
manga spin-offs of koteas I want to
thank crobat GOG for finding this
picture and for sending it to me on our
discord server and I also want to thank
soul maka and vector Maximus for helping
us to identify all of the characters on
this poster and by the way crobat GOG
makes some anime Theory videos of its
own so if you want to check your mout
the link to its channel is in the
description now on this promotional
image we can see c2 Lelouch Nunnally
Colin and Suzaku and of course we
recognize them right away we also on the
right side see Akito layla and shin
Hyuga shang from a keto DX out the rest
of the characters are from the various
manga adaptations so on the Left we see
aldrin seven and Orpheus seven and to
the right a small Marybel mell Britannia
and they're all from us of the
reflection on the very bottom we see
Renia with the steel arm and - right
below him and they are from the Shikoku
no Renia manga now regarding the meaning
of this new promotional poster there of
course two options the first is that
it's just a sort of gift for the fans oh
hey guys here we go here is an image of
all the various Code Geass characters
that appeared in the various adaptations
over the years and the second option is
that this poster is actually giving us a
hint that some of these characters that
only appeared in the spin-offs might
actually be featured in the sequel one
thing that this poster does do is that
it seems to redesign the characters a
bit and make them look more modern so if
you look at Renia he looks quite
different from his manga adaptation
because the manga actually takes place
in Edo Japan so in the past so I don't
know maybe this poster is telling us
that this new design of Renia means that
he will be coming back in the sequel and
that he will be a modern version of
himself
we don't know for sure but it's
definitely an interesting question and
an interesting piece of information so
yeah guys that's everything we know so
far about the code geass sequel as of
January 2017 if you have new information
at any time feel free to contact us feel
free to join our discord server the link
is in the description and definitely
subscribe and stay tuned to this channel
for all the latest information on Code
Geass season 3 and also on attack on
Titan season 2 and all the other awesome
anime that are coming out in 2017 and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]